au cours d
sans mon coeur qui ne
[Musique]
la culture du web et légère comme une
barbe à papa
mais les mêmes les gif et les vidéos
qu'on partage sur les réseaux sociaux
ont une double vie loin de nos appareils
ils voyagent sur une infrastructure
gigantesque en réseau qui est très
gourmands en matières premières et en
électricité et qui polluent beaucoup
surtout son cycle de vie
le secteur du numérique émet environ 4 %
de toutes nos émissions de gaz à effet
de serre c'est à peu près l'équivalent
des émissions de l'aviation civile
quand les avions sont cloués au sol par
un virus modérer ses ardeurs de voyage
c'est assez facile en temps de pandémie
on ne peut pas vraiment choix mais
qu'est ce qu'être est à mes fils croix
sur l'île de honshu
pour moi alors qu'est ce qu'on fait
[Musique]
je vais juste déposé ça ici on écrire ça
des fois en publiant un même une photo
sur facebook avec l'intention faussement
cachée de mettre le feu à l'internet
quand ça fonctionne et la publication
est très commentée et partager
normalement il n'ya pas le feu nulle
part sauf que la température monte quand
même dans un serveur quelque part dans
le monde un serveur qui se trouve dans
un centre de données qui peut être à des
milliers de kilomètres de la maison et
qui est possiblement climatisée est
alimentée en électricité avec de
l'énergie qui provient de combustibles
fossiles pour vraiment voir internet
comme une grande archives dès qu'on
clique sur quelque chose dès qu on
interagit avec du contenu on va modifier
cette archive le on peut donc dire que l
archive en tant que tel les différentes
archives sont modifiés plusieurs
milliards de fois par seconde
lc 1 de philatélie mais on pourrait
aussi l'appeler madame serveurs parce
que c'est une experte des enjeux de
sécurité informatique ont fait un clic
sur une plate forme ça peut aller à
plusieurs endroits l'internet c'est un
réseau qu'on appelle distribué donc même
si on feint clés qui ont fait une
requête d'information à un serveur qui
est physiquement à montréal s'assure que
l'information liée à cette requête le
passe par les états unis par un pays
d'europe donc à travers tout seul il va
avoir des copies en plus de cette
information le kiki veut être intercepté
un peu partout et plateformes vont créer
des copies elle-même de leurs archives
qu'elles vont distribuer dans plusieurs
endroits géographe et pour s'assurer
qu'on puisse toujours avoir accès à
notre information
le moindre petit clic génère son lot de
données supplémentaires
et on peut tenter d'évaluer la quantité
de co2 qui était mise pour gérer toutes
ces informations là si je prends les
courriels par exemple mike berners lee
qui est un chercheur spécialisé un
calcul de l'empreinte carbone et qui se
trouve à être le frère de nul autre que
tim berners lee qui est l'inventeur du
web en personne ben lui le calcul est
qu'un courriel normal équivaut à 4
grammes de co2 selon ses calculs une
année de courriels entrants ajoute 136
kg dans l'empreinte carbone d'une
personne fait l'équivalent de rouler 320
km dans une voiture compacte les
serveurs à eux seuls consomme 1 % de
toute l'électricité mondiale d'ici 2025
on veut passer de 4 à 5 milliards
d'internautes connectés et on estime que
la part des gps générés par l'industrie
des technologies pourrait doubler
l'éléphant dans la pièce ici c'est la
vidéo qui remporte la palme du poids
lourds dans notre empreinte numérique
selon des chiffes project 80 % du flux
de données en ligne est générée par le
visionnement de vidéos parce que ce sont
des contenus extrêmement dense en
information et on en consomme beaucoup
à chaque minute il ya 500 heures de
contenus qui sont téléverser sur youtube
bon dire que la vidéo c'est mal dans une
vidéo
j'aime c'est ce que vous vous dites mais
pour moi c'est juste la preuve qu'à
carbone ou en bresse nos contradictions
et c'est pas parce qu'on se rend compte
qu'on fait partie d'un problème qu'on
peut pas faire partie de la solution
la preuve c'est que beaucoup de gros
joueurs du numérique qui se creusent la
tête pour en trouver des solutions
il ya une arme et scientifiques de
partout dans le monde qui travaille fort
pour rendre les serveurs plus
écoénergétique
les géants du web comme à pau microsoft
et google se targue d'être de plus en
plus vert c'est vrai qu'ils achètent
énormément d'énergie solaire et éolienne
pour mieux refroidir leurs serveurs il
ya certaines compagnies qui espèrent des
centres de données dans les pays
nordiques comme ici au canada ou même
sous la mer tout ça c'est super
encourageant mais d'un autre côté il ya
plusieurs géants du web qui ont aussi
des partenariats avec des compagnies
pétrolières pour les aider à extraire
encore plus de combustible possible
malgré tout le travail des scientifiques
reste que si la demande énergétique du
numérique continue d'augmenter
il va falloir se poser des questions sur
notre navigation et sur notre amour des
gadgets
parce qu'il faut savoir que les gadgets
électroniques ne surpasse en nombre une
fois qu'on a pris la résolution de
réduire le nombre d'appareils
compostelle et de les bichonner de les
faire durer le plus longtemps possible
là on peut s'attaquer à la façon dont on
a vu que sur internet
mais
utiliser des outils qui permettent de
mesurer l'empreinte carbone de notre
navigation comme l'application carbone à
la dure il me dit qu'en fin de semaine
au travail j'ai émis l'équivalent de 30
km en voiture et claude tiers est
attribuable à mes courriels télécharger
les vidéos ou les musiques qu'on est
susceptible d' écouter en boucle
plutôt que de les écouter plusieurs fois
en streaming c'est un type de
consommation locale à partir de nos
appareils au lieu d'utiliser ces données
pour regarder des vidéos glu sur les
plateformes de streaming attend d'avoir
du why failli parce que les antennes
cellulaires son look plus énergivore que
la transmission de données via rail
failli s'offrir un nettoyage de notre
vie numérique mais quelque chose de
vraiment satisfaisant à faire un bon
ménage dans notre nuage et voilà et si
kanza tester des applications qui nous
aide à faire le ménage d'un doigt
courriel comme clean fox pour se
débarrasser des vieilles l'infolettre
qu'on n'oublie jamais de toute façon
chaque minute de vidéo conférence est
mais environ 15 grammes d'équivalent co2
si c'est possible éteint les caméras
après vous être élu par ses recherches
avec un moteur éco-responsable comme et
causeur qui plantent des arbres avec ses
revenus publicitaires revoir notre
politique
une étude britannique a démontré qu'on
préfère des grands gains si
collectivement on arrêtait de s'envoyer
des courriels juste pour dire merci bien
reçu une bonne vingtaine désactiver la
lecture automatique et en hd sur nos
réseaux sociaux c'est un bon début
faire des choix éclairés et diminuer
notre consommation vidéo de bébé panda
ou d'accident de skip c'est surhumain
mais ça peut se faire petit à petit on
parle de petit geste ici donc c'est avec
un effort de groupe et sur la durée
qu'on peut arriver à des résultats
vraiment intéressant mais c'est
difficile d'y arriver parce que les
sites et les réseaux sociaux sont
souvent conçues pour capter notre
attention le plus longtemps possible
les forums les internautes sont loin
d'être les seuls à faire surchauffer les
serveurs les plates formes qu'on utilise
accumulant une quantité astronomique de
données sur nos clics les compagnies
numériques vont accumuler autant de
données sur nous pour la simple et bonne
raison que c'est extrêmement profitable
si on est capable d'avoir des services
gratuits sur le web
actuellement c'est parce qu'il ya un
modèle économique au complet qui est
basée sur le fait de pouvoir construire
des profils de consommateurs et ses
profils se construisent en ramassant
beaucoup de points de données sur
autrement dit si les plateformes comme
facebook s'intéresse à nos habitudes en
ligne c'est qu'elles peuvent revendre
ces données à des publicitaires qui nous
propose ensuite des annonces ciblées
donc c'est certain qu'en tant que
citoyen faire preuve d'une sobriété
numérique ça peut être une partie de la
solution mais vraiment qu'est ce qui est
le nerf de la guerre c'est changer les
modèles d'affaires qui sont basés autour
de la collecte de données
je pense que les petits gestes peuvent
nous amener à avoir une plus grande
conscience de notre impact
environnemental et il n'y a pas de
volonté politique s'il n'y a pas une
pression citoyenne et s'il n'y a pas une
conscientisation citoyenne à la base
donc je pense que à tous - s'informer
sur ces enjeux là et être conscient de
son impact écologique c'est une très une
partie très importante du travailleur
[Musique]
y'a plus en plus de personnes qui plaide
pour une sobriété numérique
si ça vous dit d'essayer on the concocté
un petit guide sur les fuites de carbone
où vous allez trouver tous les liens
dont je vous ai parlé ensuite mahé reste
à faire des choix déchirants entrevue
vidéo chat et un contenu de carbone la
souris est embourbé et justement pour
trouver nos autres vidéos ça se passe
sur facebook
instagram youtube et même tous points tp
radio-canada vient d'ailleurs de lancer
sa nouvelle page dédiée à
l'environnement
vous y trouverez les contenus carbone et
bien plus encore
[Musique]